bonjour à tous les deux bonjour merci
beaucoup on dirait que ce matin avec
nous sur rt franc je vais commencer par
vous kerlaurent les critiques faites par
manuel bompard qui parle de
tripatouillage des sondages est ce que
pour vous c'est justifié
je ne crois pas que les sondages choisi
soit tripatouiller s'est passé pas la
question
est claire
oui mais par contre je pense que là la
bonne réflexion à avoir c'est celle qui
avait de nombreux auditeurs on vient
d'entendre il faut
écouter avec prudence les sondages parce
que les sondages donnent une vision à
l'instant t
extrêmement partiel ils sont souvent
beaucoup instrumentalisée dans un sens
ou un autre et je crois qu'il faut
surtout s'il y avait une consigne à
donner aux électeurs c'est garder votre
capacité de jugement ne me ne votez pas
en fonction des sondages mais voter en
fonction de vos idées intéressez-vous
aux débats politiques au programme des
candidats
et
essayez de vous décider en fonction de
ça je pense que ce qui pose problème
dans les sondages qui sont une mesure
parmi d'autres de l'état de l'opinion
c'est souvent l'usagé qu'on en fait et
qui sert à tordre le débat politique à
l'influencé ou à éliminer davance des
candidats qui peuvent porter un discours
extrêmement intéressant donc je pense
que c'est la manière dont on apprécie
les sondages et dont on les utilise
c'est sur ça que les électeurs devraient
être mis en alerte aux permanences est
ce qui pose problème et ça c'est l'écart
évidemment entre les sondages on l'a vu
lors des dernières élections régionales
l'écart entre les chiffres annoncés par
ces instituts et et la réalité est ce
que vous pensez que c'est ces
problématiques sébastien huyghe
non c'est logique c'est à dire que comme
l'a dit pierre laurent alors je suis pas
souvent d'accord avec les communistes
mais là je partage ce qu'il a dit c'est
que
les sondages sont une photographie à un
instant t et ce qui est intéressant
c'est finalement
l'évolution que ça donne c'est la
dynamique que ça crée c'est à dire que
entre un premier sondage est un deuxième
sondage ça donne une tendance mais mais
il ya un nouveau l'élection
le fait que nos concitoyens mettre leur
bulletin dans l'urne pour voir la
réalité des choses et donc le mode de
calcul de ces sondages je pense pose pas
de problème pour vous
ces tentatives parce que il faut être
sûr à 100% d'aller voter pour pouvoir
être comptabilisés dans ces sondages je
veux pas rentrer dans le détail mais en
gros lot
c'est clair qu'il ya toujours un billet
mais c'est une méthode de scientifique
mais qui essaye de s'approcher de la
réalité alors parfois ça correspond et
puis parfois c'est par rapport à la
question qui est posée est est en
fonction de la question qui est posée on
peut avoir un certain résultat et si on
ne regarde pas
exactement la question qui est posée le
contexte dans lequel la question est
posée avec l'ensemble des questions et
bien et comprend ça de manière tout à
fait brut on peut se tromper fortement
donc il faut regarder surtout la
tendance surtout quand c'est un sondage
qui demande pour qui vous pensé aller
voter et donc pour voir la dynamique qui
se crée plutôt demande de manière
positive ou négative par rapport à un
candidat bien laurent est ce que c'est
pas tant finalement la méthodologie ou
ou là est la crédibilité des sondages
qui est en cause mais plutôt le fait que
les médias fassent largement leurs
débats politiques justement sur sur des
sondages on est à sept mois des
élections présidentielles
bah oui c'est les deux c'est à dire que
dans y'a bon dans la mythologie pour
revenir sur ce que vous disiez c'est sûr
que les électeurs qui sont plus éloignés
du débat politique moins informés qui
souvent peuvent se décider au dernier
moment sont beaucoup plus difficiles à
sonder que les autres et puis il ya un
rapport aux repères politiques qui a
beaucoup changé ces dernières années
donc c'est sûr que les incertitudes des
sondages malgré les méthodes
scientifiques que les sondeurs utilisent
les incertitudes des sondages on grandit
donc il faut les prendre avec prudence
et les résultats des élections
d'ailleurs leur montrer d'élections
d'élections alors ensuite will usage par
les médias des sondages où il ça c'est
un vrai problème parce que au lieu
d'utiliser les sondages avec cette
prudence l'a souvent on utilise dans les
médias les sondages connaisseurs bleus
par exemple le
la manière dont on a le droit ou pas
d'avoir accès aux médias surtout dans la
dernière période de l'élection est
souvent déterminée à l'exception des
quinze derniers jours où il ya une
égalité de temps de parole et bien et
sont souvent utilisés pour écarter une
partie des candidats de l'accès aux
temps de parole sous prétexte qu'ils ne
font pas partie des autres guillemets
gros candidats grands candidats en
l'occurrence c'est ce qui arrive en tête
dans les sondages donc un usage des
sondages qui peut effectivement tordre
l'égalité de traitement des candidats et
évidemment porter atteinte à la qualité
du débat démocratique
on va écouter ce qu'on a dit eric piolle
justement de cet usage des sondages dans
les médias s'en est agacé je rappelle
que eric piolle et est candidat à la
primaire des verts
vous chercher en permanence à voir quels
seraient les différences comment on va
s'étriper quelle serait la petite phrase
et en fait ça n'arrive pas sébastien
huyghe est ce qu'il y à un usage
disproportionné abusif même temps dans
l'immédiat selon vous de ces sondages
c'est sûr qu'on en fait beaucoup est ce
qu'on peut observer c'est que le
résultat des sondages à huit mois d'une
élection présidentielle comme ont à peu
près aujourd'hui n'a jamais été le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
donc il faut prendre ça avec beaucoup de
précaution et c'est vrai que
le matraquage finalement qui a lieu avec
ces sondages par les médias donnent
l'impression à nos concitoyens que c'est
une science exacte et que
forcément par rapport aux
scores du sondage et bien c'est vrai que
le score des élections présidentielles
non je comme je le disais tout à l'heure
ça reste un outil il faut utiliser
oui avec eux avec beaucoup de précaution
alors justement ça reste un outil un
outil qui est utilisé par les
républicains justement qui ont commandé
un sondage pour tenter de départager ou
de faire émerger en tout cas un les
candidats pour pour la primaire ou pas à
droite voyez ce qu'on a dit manuel vont
pas regarder
dans certaines familles politiques la
droite l'annoncé il ya quelques jours on
va même jusqu'à commander des sondages
pour identifier le candidat le mieux
placé pour les représenter à l'élection
présidentielle sébastien huyghe c'est la
première fois je crois que les
républicains vont faire appel à un
sondage est ce que pour vous c'est la
bonne méthode
alors
on mélange tout des choux et des
carottes c'est à dire que un sondage
traditionnellement c'est sur 1000
personnes pris au hasard par la méthode
des quotas et on leur pose des questions
là c'est vraiment une étude approfondie
ce n'est pas sur 1000 personnes c'est
sur 15000 personnes
donc à ce moment là on rentre c'est plus
un sondage traditionnel signalant
qu'elle tend ses 15000 personnes c'est
alors ses 15000 personnes au départ on
parle de 30 mille personnes pour un
exact pour en arriver à 15000 qui sont
des sympathisants de la droite et du
centre qui ont déjà voté pour la droite
et le centre donc voyez on parle de
30000 on arrive à 15000 à qui on va
vraiment poser des questions pour être
sûr que ce soit des gens qui correspond
j'allais dire au panel recherché c'est à
dire des électeurs de la droite et du
centre pour leur en demander un certain
nombre de choses c'est pas simplement
vous votez vous voteriez pour tel ou tel
candidat donc il ya toute une série de
questions qui va nous permettre
d'affiner les choses et de participer au
choix du candidat et je ne peux pas
laisser dire
un sondage peu seul quand vous partez de
30000 personnes on est vraiment une
danse dans le cadre d'une étude
approfondie donc ça n'a absolument rien
à voir c'est pour sentir la sensibilité
de notre électorat par rapport aux
différents candidats qui sont candidats
on va dire à l'alcool à la candidature
mais on n'entre pas du tout dans le
cadre d'un sondage traditionnel ou en
général c'est un petit millier de
personnes à qui on pose quelques
questions alors on va s'éloigner un peu
du débat sur les sondages mais il ya un
autre moyen de sonder l'opinion on l'a
vu avec les déclarations successives du
gouvernement ces derniers jours sur les
retraites regardez
nous n'avons jamais arrêté de réformer y
compris pendant la crise
nous allons amplifier notamment avec la
réforme de l'assurance chômage au 1er
octobre la question des retraites n'a
jamais quitté la table il n'y a rien
d'enterrer la crise sanitaire a
interrompu le processus de réformes
est comme gelée redit aux partenaires
sociaux lorsque je les ai reçus la
semaine dernière ce processus dure est
modifié compte tenu des conditions
nouvelles ne pourra reprendre que
lorsque la pandémie sera sous contrôle
et que la reprise économique sera
suffisamment solide c'est une question
de bon sens
j'allais dire c'est un préalable à la
réussite de cette réforme très
importante à ce jour ces conditions ne
sont toujours pas réunies un commentaire
pierre laurent un gabriel attal avait
dit que la réforme des retraites pouvait
être engagée avant la fin du quinquennat
d'eads emmanuel macron le lendemain jean
castex dit le contraire est ce qu'on
pense des petites phrases comme ça pour
voir comment réagit l'opinion quitte à
rectifier derrière
je crois que l'intention du gouvernement
actuel est très clair et c'est le 2 de
ceux qui le soutiennent avec et de la
droite aussi ils veulent faire la cette
réforme des retraites je pense que cette
réforme serait un scandale dans la
situation actuelle il ya le secours
populaire a publié des chiffres à ces
jours ci il ya une augmentation
dramatique de la pauvreté liée à la
pandémie et on sait que les retraités
font partie malheureusement pour
beaucoup d'entre eux de cette population
touchée par la précarité la pauvreté
bien souvent à ces personnes aient
travaillé toute leur vie donc dans ces
conditions a
touché encore au système de retraite
pour abaisser le niveau des pensions
parce qu'en vérité la réforme n'a qu'un
seul objectif c'est à baisser le niveau
des pensions
ce serait un geste absolument scandaleux
dans cette situation on sait que les
inégalités se sont beaucoup développées
quant à l'assurance chômage puisque
roues par l'action d'âge
là on en a un sérieux pions d'un chèque
toutes les organisations syndicales sans
aucune exception sont contre cette
réforme et ça fait quand même quelques
millions syndiqués si on additionne
l'ensemble des syndicats donc là on a un
vrai sondage grandeur nature on sait que
l'ensemble du monde du travail etc ou
que la réforme d'assurance chômage donc
le gouvernement
prend une responsabilité extrêmement
grave en la matière dans une situation
sociale qui est déjà malheureusement
extrêmement tendues avec la pandémie
qu'en pensez vous sébastien huyghe ces
revirements sur sur le dossier des
retraites est ce qu'il faut le mettre
sur la table avant la fin du quinquennat
ou pas que pensez-vous de des
déclarations successives du gouvernement
faut-il gouverner selon vos selon
l'opinion des français
je pense que ça fait preuve de beaucoup
d'amateurisme entre un ministre qui dit
une chose et est le premier ministre qui
d autre chose et donc je pense que les
français ont besoin de savoir ce qui va
se passer en réalité et non pas le faire
en fonction
par les deux sondages tout à l'heure
c'est des sondages d'opinion par rapport
à l'élection présidentielle qui arrive
il est nécessaire de faire une réforme
des retraites notre système
déficitaire et va devenir dans de
grandes proportions c'est logique c'est
la messe c'est la baise c'est la baisse
du nombre d'actifs par rapport au nombre
de retraités et de l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie nous avions fait par
le passé un certain nombre de réformes
qu'il faut poursuivre le problème c'est
que la raison qui nous ont proposé n'est
pas la bonne celle qui permet
un déséquilibre économique important
c'est l'allongement
le recul de la date de départ à la
retraite c'est ce que nous avons fait ce
nicolas sarkozy entre 60 et 62 ans il
faut la faire mais le problème auquel
est confronté
emmanuel macron c'est que lolo moment du
bilan c'est à dire pour l'élection
présidentielle de donner le 22 le fond
c'est vont s'apercevoir qu'il n'y a pas
un bilan très important un certain
nombre de réformes ont été stoppées
certaines sont des réformes est
cosmétique qui ont été faites dans un
but de communication et aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe c'est que les stratèges à
l'elysée c'est en train de se poser la
question de savoir s'il ne faut pas
faire la traite non pas parce que elle
serait nécessaire mais parce que il faut
au moment où on fera le bilan où les
français feront le bilan pour l'élection
présidentielle est bien pouvoir dire
qu'une réforme a été fait ou non
aujourd'hui le système est et insister
et la question se pose de la
communication politique du président de
la république c'est uniquement ça la
question qu'ils se posent je trouve que
c'est assez affligeant parce que une
réforme des retraites est nécessaire
non moi je pense que c'est pas celle là
qu'il fallait faire mais on est en plus
c'est pas l'intérêt des français qui est
en question c'est l'intérêt du président
de la république pour sam élections
thériault rang voulu réagir
mais
sébastien huyghe comme le gouvernement
continue à dire que leur est la réforme
est nécessaire
parce que on a un problème de
financement des retraites c'est très
discutable parce que les preuves les
projections à long terme du conseil
d'orientation des retraites ne disent
pas ça et deuxièmement s'il ya une
réforme du financement à faire elle est
pour augmenter les ressources du système
pas pour abaisser le niveau des
retraites nogent qui inquiète les
retraites extrêmement faible et
augmenter le financement des retraites
c'est possible il faut faire reculer le
chômage y aura plus de gens qui
cotiseront il faut faire payer les
revenus financiers des entreprises qui
ne cotisent 11,0 euros aujourd'hui au
financement des retraites et ça crée une
inégalité de financement extrêmement
importante s'ils manquent de l'argent
dans les caisses de retraite c'est là
qu'il faut aller le chercher par en
tapant sur des gens qui vont finir leur
vie en travaillant jusqu'à 67 68 70 ans
avec moins de 1000 euros de retraite et
qui se retrouveront dans les
statistiques de la pauvreté qui feront
la queue dans les banques alimentaires
corse et le sac on est en train de
préparer et là dessus le gouvernement et
la droite sont totalement d'accord
débattre merci en tout cas pierre
laurent et merci à vous sébastien huyghe
y avoir accepté de débattre en direct ce
matin sur rtl france